緊張しても別にこうできる能力をうん目に
つければいいなって特集会体操クラブが
やっぱり世界を魅了しないといけないなっ
ていう思いは常に持ってますし目標に焦点
を合わせる能力と最優先の柄に集中できる
能力これがやっぱり偉大な成果を出す人の
共通校なんです
よえ今日はですねえ鎌倉市にあります特集
会体操クラブに実はお邪魔してまして
え今回パリ五輪でえ体操で大活躍をしたえ
岡選手そして杉野選手の取材を先ほどさせ
ていただきましたそしてですねこの2人の
選手を見事育て上げたえ米田さんにですね
今日はえ私このこっちの方が実ははあの
指導者育成というか指導力開発というのを
すごくメインテーマにしてるのでユさんと
の対談ものすごく楽しみに今日はしてき
ましたえ米田澤さんはま皆さんももうご
存知だと思いますがえアテネオリンピック
の金メダリストでそして特集会体操クラブ
の監督ですゆさんどうも今日はありがとう
ございます忙しい中押しかけてすいません
最初の時期は自分も指導者としてえどう
やってこのチームをえ世界一にこううん
自分が経験させてもらったような
オリンピックで金メダルを取るっていう
ようなチームにえどうやったらなるかって
いうところをえ考えていた時期でもあり
ましたしえ実際目の前で起こる結果って
いうのは全くそこにも届かないようなうん
ばかりがえ連続して起るっていうような
感じだったのでうん
えもう本当にその自分の経験を頼りに
えーーそこに近づきたいんですけどえそこ
へのたどり着き方がわからないっていう
その理想とする姿は目に浮かんでるんです
けどうんうん目の前の現状をそこに近づか
せるために何をすればいいのかがうんうん
あの分からずまとにかく一生懸命あの自分
のできることをやるっていう自分で分かる
範囲でいくとうんやっぱりこの練習に
打ち込む姿勢うんこうあとえサポートして
いる方へのえこう表し方だったりその内容
というよりもその姿勢の方が自分にとって
はすごくえ目に見えてえ気になるところ
だったのでその選手を見ながらま目の前に
いてる選手のえ願望に体操選手としてのえ
金メダルオリンピックで金メダルという
願望が果たして入ってるのかどうかうん
うんうんそのそこがうんうんなぜ入ってい
ないのであればなぜ入らないのかうんえ
じゃあ入るためにはどういう関わりをして
いけばいいのかうんなるほどそういうこと
考えながらでそんな中でえ研修もして
いただいてえ自分が思ってることを相談し
てそれを研修の形にしていただいてうん
はいそこから少しずつうんえそこを目指し
ましょうっていううん空気感が出ていくん
ですけどやっぱりそこまではうんもううん
やっぱりこれだけ特集会がえサポートして
いうんくれていてで彼らがここまで来る
社会人来るにはおそらくお父さんお母さん
とか家族とかいろんな犠牲の中で1人の
選手がここまで育ってきて
るっていうことを本当に選手1人1人は
理解しているのかどうかうんうんなんか
そういうようなことを自分が今体操ができ
ている状態をえ理解してもらうことうん
はいそこに時間を使っていたようにあの
感じますなるほどまさにこう指導者が正解
をを与えたり指導者がこうあるべきである
というまご自身の金メダリストとしての
その経験を押し付けるんではなくてその
1人1人が
本気本音本心こう内側にあるその内発的
同期付の中心にある願望をその明確にして
いくその願望の中にどうしたらより強い
その目標達成を入れられるかとま願望実現
を本人の中にどうしたら作れるかとそこに
取り組んだまず最初のステップっていう
ことなんですね
[音楽]
はい選手の心構えにもかなりばらつきが
あったんですが現役引退の1年だけこの
体育館で練習をしていたんですけどうん
うんえやっぱりこの区間の中で過ごすのが
当たり前でうんうんえま練習が5時半に
終わってもそっから自分ができることを
探して練習をするんですけどうん私が監督
に就任した時は午前中の練習がまずこの
半分が電気が消えてたんですよあそうなの
でなんでこの電気がこの半分ま自分もここ
で練習していたのでこの半分を消してる
理由が分からなくてそうすると選手がうん
あの節約であの消してるんでていう風に
言っていてなるほどうんいや目的は勝つ
ことだから
そのこれだけお金を払ってくれてる特集会
もうんこんな練習の期間に節約をして
ほしいなんて絶対望んでないからうんもう
電気なんてどれだけ使ってもいいから
とにかくももう練習が始まる前からもう
マックスで電気つけていいよっていう
なるほどっていうような感じだったり練習
が終わるとまさーっとこの中にあの消えて
いくようななるほどそういうような状態が
あの目の前にはあったのでまそう
いうのからの始まりでし
た全員に発信するっていうのは自分の中で
かっこたるものがある時じゃないですか
うんうんはいでもうん自分の中でも迷い
ながらなのでうんうん選手1人1人と話し
ながらうん選手に何が起こっているのかを
自分も知らないとうんその問題を解決でき
ないっていう風に思っていたのでうん何が
選手の中で起こっていてえま今の自分が
選手だった時とうん違うのかっていうのを
うん会話をしながらなるほどでまあの選手
がたくさん練習してくれるような施策を
色々やっていったりとかはしていったん
ですけどなるうんま本当に1人1人との
対話がなるほどあのメインでうんあのそう
することで選手を少しずつ理解していっ
たりとかうんやるべきことが見えていった
ような気がしますなるほど
[音楽]
うんあとあの監督の下にコチがいるじゃ
ないですかはいでやっぱりその高知を通し
ての指導ってのもありますよねその辺は
どんな風にその監督就任の前のコーチって
いう人をそのまま受け継いだのかそれと
はいも新たにコーチをそこで選び直して
やったのかその辺はどういう風なあと
どんな風に関わっていたのかコチそうです
ねあの自分が監督になる時にあのお金と
うんえ人事は任せてほしいあの理事長に
徳田理事長に徳田先生にもうそのうんそこ
はあの任せてくれたら自分はやりたいあ
素晴らしいっていう風に話をしてこ知人は
あのもう変えて変えてはいうんであの
スタートを切ったんですけどうんうんでも
本当に
あの自分がその時えアチーブメントの研修
を受けてダイナミックアドバンスってこう
一気にうん行かせてもらったのではいはい
もうとにかくあの共通の言葉を話せるよう
になりたいと思ってうん高知人にうんあの
全員にはい研修と受けてえはい
ダイナミックとえアドバンス受けてもらっ
てで自分の家族にもあの受けてもらって
なるべくうん自分の働く周りの人たちに
うんうん一緒にあここを目指したいこう
いうことをえ学んでる中でここで話され
てるようなことを自分もえみんなで作って
いきたいですしえこういうことが自分も
やっぱり大切だと思うていうそうすること
でうんあの共通のあの会話がうんあの
できるようになったのでうんうんあのそれ
が僕の中では1番最初まず身近に選手じゃ
なくてうん高知人にうんあの浸透させる
ためにやったことですまさにミッション
ビジョンバリューねこれをまず共通のこう
なんて言うのかなま我々の言葉で言うと
クオリティワールドという自分にとって
自分の欲求を満たす最善のイメージ写真を
共有するっていうところから最強のチー
ムっていうのがやっぱり生まれてくるん
そこをまずうんもうフルにある意味では
研修を活用しながら思考をこうまとめ上げ
てったってことですねはい本当に自分の力
ではできないと思ったのでもうとにかく
あの人にお願いするっていううんそういう
このはい感じでいろんな方にこうサポート
してもらってなるほどはい少しずつこう形
が出来上がったような気がし
ます世界を魅了する最強で最高の
チーム作りの秘訣っっていうことで
ちょっとお話を聞きたいなと思うんです
けど2022年15年ぶりに全日本体操
団体選手権で日本一になった時まずどんな
気持ちだったかそして2023年に連覇し
ましたよねその時にあたどんな気持ち
だっったのか勝つっていうことはどう
いうことを続けることで勝てるのかうん
自分も自分はえ勝った経験もありますしえ
そういうあの世界でもそういう経験をさせ
てもらったんですけどどうやったらそう
なるかが分からない中できたのでそういう
経験をされてるジュニアの高校の先生方に
えもう特集会はここまで強くなってるから
横綱ズを取った方がいいもう本当にこう
ちゃんとえできる演技でえ行った方がいい
っていう風に言われていましてそれってい
のはういうことなのかっていうのを考え
ながらやっぱりこう勝ちに行くのではなく
もう勝てる準備をしてそこで淡々と自分
たちのできる力で勝負するっていううん
勝ったことがないので勝つために今まで
一生懸命うん
あの気負ってえ試合をしていたりとか勝つ
ために必要な自分たちの力を超えたことを
やっていたりとかなるほどそういうことを
していたのかなっと思いながらえそういう
アドバイスもいただいてもう自分にたちに
できることをしっかりやってそれで勝負に
挑むて言った結果
え優勝することができたのでなるほどこう
あやっぱりその勝負に行くための準備って
いうのはえどういうことかっていうのを
その時にあのあこういう準備をして勝つ
ことができるんだなっていうのをうんあの
改めてあの理解したようなそういう瞬間
でしたうんそしてまた翌年223年にまた
入るわけですよねはいどうしても選手は
こううん勝つこと以上に強くなりたいって
いう気持ちもうんうんあるのでえ強くなる
もちろん強くなることがえオリンピックの
金メダルだったりオリンピックの代表に
つがるんだけどうんうん強いだけじゃ
やっぱり持ってる力を発揮できないとその
舞台には立てないのでうん少しでもえ選手
のえやりたいうん気持ちを抑えてでも
価値にこわるっていうそういうことを2年
目もあの選手と話をして選手はここまで
やりたいかもしれないけどえチームとして
はまず2連覇を1番にえ目的としておく
からねっていうことでえ2連覇に向けて
それぞれが勝てる演技構成で
えあの練習していたっていうような形が2
年目だったのでうんなんかやっぱりその
できる力をえ本番で発揮するっていう自分
の力以上のことをうんうんえ求めないと
いうかうんはい本当にそれは第2証言とし
てうんあのその先のことをこうちゃんと
取り組んでいてえうん目の前ではしっかり
こう価値にこだわるようなうんそんな形で
練習は進めていました監督に就任してから
も変わらないんでしょうけれどもやっぱり
こう遅れの法則が働いてようやく時間は
かかったけれどもそういう思いが伝わって
またまとまってそのエネルギー文化が作ら
れてそしてやるべきこと集中の法則とか
いろんなものが整えられてそういう現象が
こう生まれたということなんでしょう
ね界を魅了する最強で最高のチームという
スローガンをえ今からどうでしょう7年か
8年ぐらい前ですか作ったのははいそう
ですねはいそれを作られたまちょうど
私たちも研修でねお手伝いをさせて
いただいてそのスローガンが生まれたわけ
ですよねこのちょうど垂れ幕にもなってる
んですけどはいこれをこう作られてから
やっぱりチームで多少その変化っていうの
は生まれてきましたかちょうど作ったに
キャプテンをしていたのが亀山えだったの
ではい平さんはいで世界を魅了する最強で
最高のチームを目指すやっぱりあの結果
だけじゃなくてえ人としても最高であれる
ようにっていうことでそういうスローガン
がえ掲げられてうんやぱそのそこからは
チームとしてこの最強で最高にふさわしい
行動なのかどうかっていうことは
こう考えをうんえ決めていくための1つの
この指標になることが多くうんあったので
やっぱり何かこう自分たちのチームの
目指すえものを掲げるっていうのはすごく
大事なんだなっていう風に思いました
なるほどそうすることで選手もえやっぱり
自分たちは世界を魅了する最強で最高の
チームを目指していますっていうことが
全員にこううん浸透されていくのでこ自分
たちが高知人から選手に伝えることも
すごくこう通りやすくなるほどなりましな
なぜ自分たちがこういうことを選手に提案
しているのかうんそういったこともあの今
もオリンピック終わってから忙しく選手は
してますけどうんそういうこともやっぱり
最強そして最高やっぱ世界を魅了していき
たいっていう
自分たちの目指す方向に向けて選手たちも
色々こうできることをやってくれるので
こうま本当にこう方向性が1つにあのなる
ために重要なことだったんだなっていう風
に思いまし
たえ世界の舞台で活躍できる選手と活躍
できない選手を分ける決定的な差って何
ですか
ふ今までたくさんの選手見てきたでしょ
はいみんな頑張ってきたじゃないですか
子供の頃からでやっぱり特集会体操クラブ
に入れる子でやっぱりある程度そういう目
をかけられる子っていうのは親もすごい
大化の先払いもしてうんすごい大償払って
きてますよねはいだけどやっぱり伸びも子
っているじゃないですかうんその決定的
もちろん先天的なものはあると思うんです
よでもその個人の
違いっって何なんだろうと自分の目の前で
活躍している選手の共通点でいく
と
やっぱり
あの全てに素かどうか分からないんです
けどそ結果を出すことに関する素直
さ
と影響の受けやすさみたいな感じ
はえ感じる部分ありますすごく影響を
受けるそれがいい影響に受けたらすごく
いい方向に行きますしそこの影響の受け方
で
あのまその瞬間はうん違うものに受けてる
かも分からないですけどやっぱりこの触れ
た時の純粋にそこに行くうん触れ方って
いう
かそういう部分はあの
感じますうんはいなるほどこう何かに
出会ってもらった時に影響を受けてポンっ
て変わるっっていううんそういう感じは
すごく感じるのでまある意味で伸び悩む
伸び悩むというかそういう意味でのま感受
性微弱というかやぱ伸びない子はどっち
かてとがというかやっぱり自分というもの
から出れないというかそういうのがあ
るってことですかねうん例えば之けでいく
とうんえ北当時の時にこう練習があんまり
良くなかった時にうんあの話をして本当に
こう何のために岡山から来たのかうんうん
うんまこういう練習をするなら特集会にい
ててもしょうがないうんこれだったら岡山
にいててもいいと思ううんどういう思いで
ま本人も岡山から来たのかうんうんどう
いう思いで先生たちもこっちに送ってくれ
たかそこはやっぱり考えてほしいっていう
ことをま今となっては自分はそんなにこう
社会人しかうんえ指導したことがなかった
のでそういうこう高校1年生のまだつい
最近まで中学生だった選手にはどこまで
理解してたのかわからないんですけどその
火の練習の動きが全然違ってあ
やっぱりそういう何かをこっちがだったり
アクション起こすとほう
あ動きがこういう風に変わるんだなって
いううん風に思いましたしやっぱりこの
何かと出会った時にポンっていくなるほど
はい指導をする上でご自身が今とてもこう
大切にしていること日々何
が正しいのかうん
え
こうそれを模索しながらやっている部分は
あるんですけどやっぱり自分の意識として
は選手がオリンピックのうん金メダルをえ
目指すのであれば
そのうん姿勢にえふさわしい自分のあり方
っていううんそこはそのよんと揃えられる
ように選手はやっぱりオリンピックの金
メダルを取るためにえいい時もあればえ
良くない時もあるっていう日々を過ごして
その中でやっぱりこう自己実現をこううん
ま目指していくうんでそこにふさわしい
自分であれるのかどうかっていううんうん
そこをあの選手にうん追いつけるよう
にっていうことともし選手が追いついてい
ないのであれば自分のあり方はそこに
ちゃんといてるのかそこから選手にえ指示
ができてるのかどうかっていうことをまず
は
あの間違わないようにちゃんと自分がそこ
に入れてるかっていうのはあの考えるよう
に接しています素晴らしいもうこれはもう
日本中の全ての親に聞かしたい話だなこれ
やっぱり自分が仕事に対して情熱持って
なければ口でいくら勉強しろとか色々強制
してもねそれはやっぱりね子供はね頑張ら
ない同じことが会社でも言えてると思うん
ですよ僕はやっぱり指導者ですから部下を
しっかり育てながらまあ置いて老害になる
前には引退しますけどもう最後までね僕も
ね生涯元気やろうと思ってるんですけど
いや今のねあのユナさんの一言聞いてね
啓発されました私もやっぱり常に社員から
見ていやあ自分も社長のように人材教育に
命をかけてイツワークアンドワークで一生
懸命あんなに頑張って喜びを持って働い
てる自分もやっぱり頑張ろうって思って
もらえるようなまそういうやっぱり指導者
でありたいなとうん思いましたですね
素晴らしいな本当にその問いですよねあの
やっぱりあり方ですよねやり方よりもあり
方うんだやっぱり今のお話を聞いてもあり
方を米田さんのあり方が岡選手次の選手と
いう偉大な選手を育てた本質なんだなと
今日確認できました今日はね本当にあの
深いお話ができて嬉しいですです人生は
出会いで決まる今夜の後年あっという間の
10年近い歳月が流れましたけどまお互い
にとって本当に私は出会えて良かったと
思いますしこれからも体操日本盛り上げて
いきましょう今日ありがとうございました
ありがとうござい
[音楽]
ます人間ってでもなんだろうやっぱり中に
内在する可能力をどこまで引き出し
てもらえる指導者に出会えるかっていうの
も大きいんだよ決して指導者って甘い指導
車にあっちゃうとダメなんです
よ僕はやっぱり弱さから来る優しさと強さ
から来る優しさ真の優しさっていうのは
健全なやっぱり強さが後ろにあると僕は
思ってるね僕は非常に厳しいんですよある
意味ではただ洗濯にアプローチを取ってる
だけなんですね外的コントロール使う方が
楽なんですよ立場で言えるから選択にのの
方が大変です忍耐こっちが耐えて忍耐し
ながら正解を本人の中に作らせなければ
いけませんよね本人の中に答えはあるので
うんこれはチャレンジしいがあるなと
うんま本当にこれからもさらに良い組織を
私も作ってきますのではいよろしくお願い
します今日ありがとうございました